hi this is presh talwalkar i'm going to
teach you a trick from vedic mathematics
so you can quickly square a number that
ends in the digit 5.
you'll be able to square this number
faster than you can do on a calculator
and you'll be able to do it in your head
let's say you want to do 25 squared
the trick is that just take the the
digit that's not 5
and multiply it by 1 more than itself
so 2 times 1 more than itself is 3
and you get the number 6.
then put the number 25 at the end
and that will be your answer 25 squared
is 625
we'll do another example
let's say you want to do 55 squared
we take the digit that's not 5
and we multiply it by one more than
itself
five times six is thirty
and so we get after adding the
twenty-five that fifty-five squared is
thirty-twenty-five
the general procedure is if you have a
number that ends in the digit 5
you take one more
than the number itself
you write that down
and you add the number 25 at the end
i like to end on this example to keep
students interested
205 we take 20
times 1 more than itself
and we get 420
25.
i hope you like this trick
please watch the video where i explain
why this works
you can catch me on my blog
bindyourdecisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker or get my
ebooks at amazon